is Something official about to happen
for Babylon 5 are we about to get the
big announcement welcome to Sidetrack
your Sci-Fi TV and movie channel
[Music]
so Jay Michael korsinski or JMS because
that's a lot easier to say and they'll
start on Twitter oh God nearly a year
ago now that he had written a script for
the Babylon 5 reboot and it was ready to
go it was hoping to get that script
filmed and if it all went well green lit
and have the TV show actually on our
screens by well roughly now but it just
didn't happen the CW didn't push forward
to making the script now there are a lot
of reasons why that happened
for one it was about the time that the
CW went up for sale and Warner Brothers
decided to take a big step back away
from that Network also Warner Brothers
is going through a big restructure
itself it is merging with discovering
Inc creating Warner Brothers Discovery
so that has caused a lot of issues with
them themselves it's one of the big
reasons why the Batgirl movie didn't get
made and lots of other Warner Brother
projects have been put on the back
burner all of these things take a lot of
effort from a business and it's quite
difficult to carry on with big major
creative projects when all of that
turmoil is going on but all of that
turmoil is coming to an end they are
getting themselves organized and big
projects are about to be announced there
is a new CEO in charge of Warner
Brothers Inc and they own hbr Max the CW
has a new owner and they're coming in as
well but they have been announcing a lot
of quite interesting things including a
big change in direction for the CW
including a move away from lots of the
Sci-Fi and sort of superhero TV shows
that we've been used to from that
Network so what does that mean for
Babylon 5 and why do I think there's a
big announcement about to happen well
JMS has been on Twitter but before I
tell you about that let me tell you what
I've been told about Babylon 5 quite a
few times over the last six months for
one I was told even before this it was
announced that CW weren't moving forward
to Babylon five and I did tell you guys
as well the Babylon fight was never
actually going to make it to the CW that
Warner Brothers were almost certainly
going to switch it to HBO Max oh by the
way if you do like the content please
consider hitting the join button and
becoming a fully fledged side tracker
you can also go to sidetrack.com and
pick marvelous merchandise all of these
little things really help the channel
also if you're new to the channel like
subscribe hit that Bell notification and
share the video wherever the hell you
want now I was actually told that it
might end up on CW eventually but that
primarily it would end up on HBO on Max
because that's Warner Brothers primary
streaming service it's where they make
their big money and then it would follow
up on the CW at a slightly later date
now what I'm told at the moment is that
might still be the plan but it very much
depends on the CW's new owners whether
they're willing to pay for it but
what I'm being told is HBO Max is 100
behind JMS creating Babylon 5 and if it
gets made which I'm going to talk about
that in a second as well it will end up
on HBO Max first
so
first of all I've got to tell you that
the CW don't actually own the production
rights or anything like that of Babylon
5. it is and always was Warner Brothers
um in cooperation with the jms's own
production company
so the CW don't actually have any rights
to produce Babylon 5 but there is what
I'm being told some contractual issues
because they did initially produce JMS
to write the script so they technically
own potentially the pilot the JMS is
written so that's one problem but not a
major one particularly if the CW don't
actually want to move forwards with that
type of genre of material and that type
of TV but also
the CW is still at least partly owned by
Warner Brothers I think they're dropping
down to 10 of the ownership and they're
still going to be producing material and
content for the CW so that's not a
relationship to see the new owners of
the CW really want to mess around with
too much they're not going to rock the
boat that much and say well you can't
have Babylon five if if Warner Brothers
decide they want it so I I think there's
some minor issues there that are being
resolved at the moment
because they're not no not major at all
the other thing is Warner Brothers love
shows like Babylon 5. they want shows
like that on HBO Max because that's the
sort of show that just lives on
streaming services on the big networks
it was always about viewing figures and
selling advert time so it was
advertisers wanting to put their adverts
on the big shows and when they auction
off that advertisement time the more
views a show is getting the more people
that are watching the more the network
could charge the advertisers for space
nowadays it doesn't work like that all
they really care about is subscribers
and a show like Babylon 5 will draw in a
very cult following of subscribers it
might not be tens of Millions
but it will be enough to Warrant the TV
show and that is what HBO Max loves but
also there's another thing about the
show like Babylon 5. people don't just
watch it once they will watch it
repeatedly this is one of those things
with big sci-fi shows which why the
streamer Services it's why Disney love
shows like the Mandalorian and Marvel
it's because people watch them over and
over and over again because we're
obsessive nerds so HTTP on Max which
actually has the original Babylon 5
series now 100 wants the new Babylon 5
reboot
but there has been some movement
JMS has been on Twitter one day ago he
wrote the message
something is moving now I'm a bit
cryptic but he likes his cryptic
messages for me I think he is perhaps
hinting that there has been a
breakthrough with a Babylon 5 reboot
again if what I'm being told is correct
it's that actually the movement is that
HBO Max is going to be the new home and
not the CW but then a couple of hours
after that he wrote another message
it's never been my way to ask B5 fans
and followers for a solid on behalf of
the show because I feel it's my role and
the role of the show to be of service to
you not the other way around but
tomorrow for the first time in 22 years
I will ask now what is JMS going to be
asking
I think there's a couple of
possibilities but we're gonna find out
really soon actually in the next couple
of hours potentially what exactly it is
he wants us to do but he might be asking
us to do a Twitter store maybe some of
that to try to build up a bit of
momentum behind the show to try and get
that final green light so this dropped
while editing it's a Twitter storm folks
now obviously JMS is still here pushing
for the CW but notice that he mentions
how important the Warner Brothers
decision is so
let's follow the hashtag let's get
twitting and let's get Babylon 5 made
but please go over onto his Twitter feed
have a look when he asks the question
answer because this is a show I always
thought he's like
it used to be called the poor man's Star
Trek Babylon 5 but I always thought that
was really unfair because I actually
thought it was far more creative in lots
of ways than Star Trek ever was uh most
definitely more creative than any of the
new track
it deserves it and and you've got to
realize as well it's been 25 years since
Babylon 5 was off our screens 25 years
that's a quarter of a century
and people still watch this show and
people are still massive followers of
this show that just shows you really how
great this TV series was and how
creative it was
so for me whatever JMS wants I'm there
my sword is his I will go out there on
the battlefield for him and scream as
loud as I can bring back Babylon 5.
so guys please get over to his Twitter
but also get into the comments here like
and share the video let's get the signal
out there that we want Babylon 5 back
and we want it now now if that means
it's going to go into HBO and Max
that's a problem because that's behind a
paywall but hopefully if it's popular
enough it will end up on the CW just
afterwards now don't get me wrong the CW
is a crap Network and
um but HBO Max is actually a reasonably
good Network they do tend to make quite
Brave TV shows so hey
let's get it out there and let's see
what happens and let's just hope that we
all get to love the final result
so if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out also
if you enjoy the content please hit the
join button because that really supports
the channel as always stay safe I'll see
you next time
[Music]